a recording has been released of donald
trump demanding that officials in
georgia
find thousands of extra votes to
overturn the result of the election
the people of georgia are angry and
these numbers are going to be repeated
on monday night along with others that
we're going to have by that time which
are much
more substantial even and the people of
georgia are angry the people of the
country are angry
and there's nothing wrong with saying
that you know uh
that you've recalculated well mr
president the challenge that you have
is the data you have is wrong look all i
want to do
is this i just want to find uh
11 780
votes which is one more that we have
because we won the state
well our u.s correspondent greg milam
joins us now from atlanta
georgia so greg tell us more what else
did the president say then in this call
well there was quite a lot it went on
for an hour that call on on saturday
afternoon 3 p.m on saturday afternoon
and a lot of the themes were
pretty familiar the things donald
trump's been talking about since the
election in november that he actually
won
that there was widespread fraud although
as we know there's been no proof of that
widespread fraud
but what was most surprising was how
blatant what we just heard was
calling on the the secretary of state of
georgia who is a republican remember
to find just enough votes to take him
past joe biden
to explain that away to the american
people as saying there have been a
recalculation
uh threatening some kind of vague legal
action against the secretary of state
if that uh if that didn't happen so
remarkable to hear all of that and a
real glimpse into donald trump's mindset
even now what two weeks
away from the inauguration of joe biden
that he is still pushing this and
believes it can be
uh overturned now the secretary of state
stood firm said there wasn't any
evidence to back up any of what donald
trump was saying
even when donald trump brought up a
debunked conspiracy theory about
dominion now they make the voting
machines
there's been this theory that machines
have moved around in a shady fashion
he brought that up and the other
official on the call responded here's
that moment from the call
dominion is really moving fast to get
rid of their
uh machinery do you know anything about
that
because that's illegal ryan germany no
dominion has not
um moved any machinery out of fulton
county we're having well but
but if they move have they have they
moved
the inner parts of the machines and
replaced them with other parts
no he's your ryan
i'm sure
now at the end of that hour-long call
donald trump seemed to realize he wasn't
getting anywhere in fact he said that
this call is going nowhere and
while it might not make any difference
to that election that happened in
november
it might have an impact on what's
happening here in georgia this week
there is a runoff election
for two seats in the u.s senate that if
democrats win them
would effectively give them control of
the the upper house the senate in
washington
and give joe biden much more power in
what he's able to do as as president
and republicans here in georgia are very
worried that every time donald trump
says
the election is rigged it's not worth
any of the paper it was written on
it means some republicans think well
it's not worth going out to vote and if
they do that here this week in georgia
it could hand those senate seats to the
democrats and donald trump has said he
will talk about this more
when he comes to georgia tomorrow to
rally for those
those senate seats so it's not going
away and that is a concern for
republicans
greg thank you